les apiculteurs français sont inquiets
les abeilles ont modifié leur
comportement depuis qu'elles butinent
détourne seul pulvérisé par un
insecticide très puissant mais il
n'existe pas la moindre preuve pour en
avoir le coeur net trois départements
l'indre les deux sèvres et la vendée
n'utiliseront plus se produit lors des
semis des tournesols au printemps à ne
pas signer grégoire rosina comme cette
semaine le temps est aux grilles et à la
pluie
les abeilles reste au chaud sauf si
c'est maurice marie leur apiculteur qui
frappent à la porte parce que ça doit
faire quand vous faites cela elles
réagissent aussitôt petit bruit là est
en fait aujourd'hui et elles entendent
le soleil pour donner le coup de sifflet
de départ pour s'en aller sur les
floraisons de colza voisine le colza
c'est la première fleur de la saison ce
que les apiculteurs craignent c'est
l'arrivée d'une autre fleur jaune
tournesol en juillet depuis trois ans au
moment où il fleurit la production de
miel chute brutalement les apiculteurs
sont convaincus que le nouvel
insecticide qui traite le tournesol
désoriente leurs abeilles dès le début
de la floraison les le bataillon de
butineuses ses principes et elles sont
très attirées par le fond marin et c'est
là qu'on a les pertes de butineuses qui
sont là et ensuite évidemment pertes de
récolte cette année donc dans trois
départements
on ne livre plus cet insecticide appelé
le gaucho il est interdit et graines de
tournesol ne sont plus enrobée de
produits rose mais d'un autre traitement
bleus moins performant en utilisant
celui ci on est obligé d'utiliser en
plus un insecticide à part sur le haut
soumis plus éventuellement un
insecticide en végétation donc un
surcoût d'environ 100 à 150 francs
avec ta mais les agriculteurs de l'indre
sont compréhensifs car ils ont autant
besoin d'abeilles que insecticides dans
ce chant pascal à marie produit des
graines de carottes certains rangs sont
mal d'autres femelles les abeilles
assurent la fécondation complètement
demande à un apiculteur de la région de
disposer des russes dans la parcelle ou
en bout de la parcelle pour lesquels
féconde
no no no fleurs de carottes si dans
l'indre cet été les abeilles retrouvent
le chemin de la ruche après avoir butiné
le tournesol sans gauche on le doute
sera levé c'est bien cet insecticide qui
depuis trois ans leur faisait perdre la
tête